if functional training is preparing
yourself for life or for your chosen
sport then Super functional training is
going beyond that training in ways that
you don't need just because it's awesome
I don't need to Bench close to double
body weight but I want to because it's
awesome I don't need to do handstands
throw clean punches Sprint or do front
hands Springs super functional training
also means not training in an exclusive
capacity it means not only being strong
not only having endurance but being all
of those things you going be as strong
as you could be if you focused on that
exclusively but you will be more of an
allrounder being super functional means
rolling jumping climbing lifting and
fighting it means combining ideas from
different styles of training pushing the
limits and having fun if you want to
train like this then you can check out
my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 it comes with an
85 Plus page ebook and over 2 hours of
instructional video and at the time of
upload is on heavy discount for a couple
more days Link in the first comment
below